종로의 좀 저는 장점이라고 생각하면
뭔가 예전에 역사적인 그런 문화가
담겨 있는 그런 건축물들이 되게 많고
경복궁이 그지 인사동이 그지 아니면
북촌 한옥 마을이라는 예전의 모습과
현대의 모습이 약간 믹스되어 있는
그런 곳이라고 보시면 될 거 같아요네
그리고 제가 종로에서 종강력 상권을
좀 설명드리려고 하는데 종강력 상권은
1980년도에 90년도에 서울을
대표하는 그런
상권이었다 이라든지대 기업이라는 이런
관공서들이 많이 밀집되어 있다 보니까
젊음의 거리라고 해서 직장인 타켓으로
한 거리가 생기기 시작합니다 그러면서
인근의 카페라는 음식점 클럽 등이
생기면서 활발하게 운영이 되었고
이때가 젊음의 거리가 활성화되기
시작했던 시기라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그리고 2000년도 중반부터
2010년도 초반까지는 정말 젊음의
거리 그러니까 종강력 상권이
황금기라고 좀 불리게 되는데 이때는
명동처럼 정말 주말에는 사람이 엄청
바글바글했고 다양한 행사들이 좀 많이
열려서 그걸 보기 위해서 사람들이 또
많이 몰리기도 했습니다 그리고 젊음의
거리는 단순하게 소비하는 장소가
아니라 이렇게 젊은 세력들이 만나서
뭔가 교류하고 뭔가 새로운 문화를
경험하기 위해서 굉장히 좀 잘 형성된
상권이었다 중반 때 대형
프랜차이즈들이 많이 들어가면서이
종강력 상권이 색깔을 잃게 됩니다
그리고 주변에 대체할 만한 상권들이
생기게 돼요 홍대라는 이태원이라는
이쪽으로 젊은 사람들이 많이 분산이
되면서 상권이 이제 몰락의 길을 걷게
됩니다 2010년도 중반부터
2020년 초반까지 상권이 너무 안
좋아졌었는데 공실인 경우도 많았고
그래서 제가 그때 당시에 거기 인근의
오피스에 한 2년 정도 있었는데
사람이 없었어요 그러다가 진짜 오래
전부터 공실인 건물들이 지금 차기
시작했습니다 물론 이제 되게 좋은
임차인은 아니지만 그래도 임대가 됐고
있어요 그래서 그 이유가 뭐냐면 대형
프랜차이즈 업체들 때문에 임대료가
되게 높았 말이에요 그래서 나중에
이제 이게 임차인이 나가도 그 높은
임대료로 마치기가 되게 어려워요 근데
건물주 분들이 계속 몇 년째 공실이
보니까이 임대료를 내리기 시작했습니다
무엇보다 우리나라에 외국인 관광
계획이 많이 늘었어요 천개 천을 많이
오거든요 그 천개 천을 진짜 걷다가
종강력 상권에 오기도 하고 그래서
저도 뭐 현장 가서 봤지만 외국인
관광객 비율도 되게 높아졌어요 그래서
그러다 보니까 오랫동안 공실이 있던
건물이 임대가 들어오기 시작했습니다
그래서 상권이 회복되고 있는 단계다
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다 관철동
상권 전망을 좀 하자면 지금 조금씩
회복되고 있긴 하지만 관철 동만의
특색 있는 상권을 만드는게 되게
중요한 거 같아요 좀 더 이제 젊은
사람들이 오기 좋게 아니면 이제 좀
특색 있게 거리를 조금 만들어야 될
필요가 있다라고 생각하고 아니면 그
앞에 청계천이 되게 좋거든요 청계천이
진짜 사람도 많이 다니고 외국인도
많이 찾거든요 청계천과 연계된 뭔가
그런 거를 만들면 된 전는 되게 좋을
거 같아요 뭐 이태원이라는 뭐
홍대라는 청계천을 접하고 있지
않잖아요 근데 관철동 청계천을 접하고
있습니다 바로 앞에 있어요 그래서
청계천과 연관된 그런 거를 좀 해
가지고 뭔가 여기에 상권이 좀 더
발달될 수 있게 그렇게 하면은 좀 더
좋지 않을까 그리고 여기 종강력 상권
자체가 좋은게 뭐냐면 교통이 너무
좋아요 진입하기도 너무 좋고 역과의
거리도 너무 가깝고 그 어딜 가든
되게 좋은 위치에 있어 일단
지리적으로 너무 좋은 점이 있고
외국인들이 또 많이 오는 부분이
있습니다 인근에 뭐 숙소를 많이
얻거나 그리고 이제 명동이랑 거리가
그렇게 멀지 않기 때문에 외국인들
수요도 많이 흡수할 수 있어요 그래서
그런 부분을 잘 좀 활용해서 관철동의
그런 특색 기는 상권을 만든다라고
하면 진짜 황금기 때 느꼈던 그런
명성을 다시 얻을 수 있지 않을까
이렇게 생각을 합니다 그리고 종로
검을 보시면은 건물이 따닥따닥 다
붙어 있잖아요 그래서 예전에 지은
건물들이 많아요 진짜 막 50년대
60년대 그래서 건폐율이 막 100%
아니면 초과하는 건물들이 많거든요
그래서 그 땅의 효율성을 최대한
활용해서 쓴 건물들이 많아요 그래서
그때 당시에는 적법하게 허가를
받았지만 지금 만약에 여러분들이
신축을 하게 되면 건폐율이 다시
줄어요 그래서 여러분들이 종로의
건물을 사실 때는 그 부분을 좀
주의하셔야 돼요 그리고 지금이
지역뿐만 아니라 오랜 기간 동안
상권이 침체되거나 아니면 유지됐던
아니면 안 좋아졌던 그런 곳 같은
경우에는 임대 시세나 매매 시세를
되게 냉정하게 봐야 되고 그리고 그고
최근 사례를 봐야 돼요 그래서 예를
들어서 예전에 이제 호환기 때 임대
수익률을 뭐 예를 들어서 4%
마쳤다고 하면 보통은 그냥 수익률만
보고 사거든요 근데 만약에 이제
그렇게 맞춰서 사는데 나중에 임차인이
나가서 새로 임차를 맞출 때 수익률이
더 낮아질 수도 있거든요 그래서 임대
사례도 최근 걸 보셔야 되고 그리고
지금 인근에 나와 있는 임대 시세를
조사를 하셔야 되고 그리고 매매
사례도 10년 전에도 거기 관철동
가격이 매우 비쌌어요 그래서 그
사람이 매입한 금액 가지고 금액이
얼마 깎여 가지고 이게 급매라고
생각할 수도 있는데 그런 것도 되게
조심해야 되고 오랜 기간 동안 이렇게
침체에 있었으니까 그리고 임대료가
낮아지면 그 매매 가격이 낮아지나요
그것도 같이 반영을 해 가지고 이렇게
매각 사례도 최근 매각 사례를 보시고
참고하시는게 중요합니다 어 일단은
종강력 상권에 대해서 좀 얘기해
봤는데 변화하고 있는 모습들이 보여서
앞으로 좀이 상권이 어떻게 될지 좀
기대되기도 합니다 그래서 오늘은
여기까지 하겠습니다 빌딩은 역시
빌사남
l
[음악]